Amsterdam has a population of more than
800,000 and even if the seat of the
government is the hague this is the
capital of the Netherlands the four-star
hotel venas plane has just opened in a
city centre self-proclaimed hotel
reviewer Vincent Van Dyke suggested we
meet there two and a half years after
starting his project he still hasn't
lost interest in hotels I have an
addiction I guess when I enter out like
I feel at home immediately especially
like here and it's like a living room
that's why Vincent Van Dyke still enjoys
hanging out in a hotels restaurants and
bars when he's not at work running a
successful public relations firm
following Amsterdam's countless crafts
or canals is a traditional way to see
the old town the waterways once served
as the city's transport grid
but today Vincent would rather show me
some of this city's newer attractions
the sky lounge at the top of the
doubletree hotel is located near the
central rail station outside on a clear
day it affords a panoramic view when it
rains there's the same view from the
inside we take a look at our report on
Vincent from 2010 back then he was in
the thick of his project sleeping at a
different Amsterdam Hotel every night
and blogging about it he got the idea
when he first moved here we couldn't
find a place to live so he decided to
write a book about his experiences the
book has been a big success and even
though it's been more than two years
since he finished his adventure people
are still talking about it
still people are inviting me to do
interviews in all over the world and I'm
conceived in hotels all over the world
so more than two years after that
project that people still remember that
still every week people approached me
for that or people want to coffee here
the projects in their own country we
move on to the harbor Vincent is always
on the lookout for offbeat accommodation
after the hotel project he got a chance
to move into an old sailing boat in the
old open harbor Museum due to a chronic
housing shortage houseboats are common
in Amsterdam there are some 2,500 of
them ward on the canals
you couldn't think of living in an
apartment or after after your hotel
project now the in the hotel's I had a
holiday feeling all the time and I'm
addicted to that and I have the same
feeling here this doesn't feel like
living this is like like vacation
theoretically he could take his home
around town but in the north of
Amsterdam we opted for a ferry in recent
years numerous hotels and museums have
sprung up here including the I film
Museum which opened just a year ago
Vincent sees the architecture as a
splendid example of modern Amsterdam
and this is where I find my souvenir for
the Euro max prize draw a fabric map of
Amsterdam and you can Rumple it up as
much as you want early evening and it's
time for a drink and a good place for
that of course is a hotel visiting heads
of state and celebrities often stay at
the amstel vincent's overnight stay was
on the house this is one of the I
conserve Amsterdam uh-huh yeah the most
famous hotel I guess in the ground floor
bar we sip a cocktail made of gin
lavender and a raw egg Vincent Van Dyke
has had a flood of offers from
international hotel associations for
similar projects but he'd rather stay in
Amsterdam the nomadic PR manager has put
his roots down here even if they're in
water for now